Who's the bird headed god of Egypt,
who I told you about,
who represents the capacity to pay attention.
Very important concept because the Egyptians realized and really it's brilliant.
It is something modern people do not understand cause we tend to make
rationality the highest God that's,
that's not a good thing.
That's a pathway to totalitarianism.
What the Egyptians knew,
but they only knew it in symbolic form was it was the capacity to attend to
things that in some sense was the highest psychological function because it's
the capacity to pay attention that actually moves you beyond what you only know.
And rationality tends to make,
you know,
integral systems that are coherent,
that are boxlike and then claim that they're absolutely right.
Whereas the tension is always looking beyond what you know.
And,
and attention is an unbelievably powerful force.
You know,
that's why advertisers pay for it.
That's why people demand it.
That's why children can't live without it.
That's why it's what you want from your friends and your family.
You want them to pay attention to you.
It's an unbelievably valuable resource.
And so one of the things I always tell my clients,
for example,
if they're socially anxious,
I say,
look,
pay more attention to the person you're talking to.
If you pay,
if you really pay close attention to them,
then the thoughts that are making you anxious will be suppressed.
And because you're paying close attention to them,
you'll match your movements to theirs and you'll match your conversation to
them.
And then there's no reason for you to be socially anxious cause socially
anxious.
People will go like this when they're talking,
you know,
they don't want look at you of course,
how the hell can you engage anyone if you're not in a little dance with them,
you know you can't.
And a lot of it's non verbal,
it's physical and it's embodied and without paying attention then you lose
people.
And you see this with speakers all the time too.
There in front of audiences,
they have their paper and they're going like this.
And usually they're talking like this too.
And you know the logical thing to do in that case is like look at Facebook or
get the hell out of there something.
But they're not paying attention to the audience,
and so there's no power in the,
there's no power in the dynamic conversation at all.